[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the book
I'm forum working on my thesis I've been
marking out where my Chester's
interviewing and what happens is lawful
and things are actually fighting to come
together like feeling like I'm out the
Glinka proper uses three scary
[Music]
so the men that there are two things I'm
working on basically one is one last bit
of code like a little is this continuity
problem we've been having for a while
and trying to fix one snaps them and
literally I can get a date for a thesis
chance of any overnight which is
exciting
now I add that skypes people that he
janessa because it's exactly this ago
that we finished the create account so
and then our friends certain yet well
example having a catch-up and seeing how
gravity's doing I think most guarantee
that everybody will in a more videos
than me which look at the timeline leg
here we go ah so the call has been
delayed so I'm actually my Q's recent
thesis Corrections will stay wait for
it's going to happen got it working in
the end I was actually really nice just
basically had a quick catch-up now we're
off to do some singing but we I am going
to uni here has some just outrageous
perks like there's campus that's the
view in fact you can see up that
alleyway of trees that's chapel and
through the trees up there that's the
building I think that has the the ladies
bathroom inspired moaning myrtles
bathroom because JK Rowling went to uni
here and well Shh cam like The Bourne
Ultimatum so where that guy standing
over there I tried to fly a caress my
drone and I was very private so oh hey
hey how did it go so I just bumped into
a friend of mine who just did his Viper
so he's just finished all I saying
trying to fight Icarus down there at the
bottom of a hill and I was told politely
that I couldn't have it do any drone
stuff on campus again because privacy
stuff which is fair enough
not that it mattered in the end after
what happened to Icarus
[Music]
so I did find a yeast for him in the
recent heat wave
[Music]
ah I'm about curious at Martin's another
gig
say hi Sophie I said say hi Sophie so we
just did a sing song and we've come to
the person who organizes it was flat
because they put on some food to say
thank you and let's get this view how
amazing is that even the even row you
think the cathedral with the made by
there I mean if you say you're on the
inside of that normally yeah I don't get
such a good evening son to lay down in
thanks pixel girl
[Music]
so outside of music and dinner we're now
in the firehouse to the touch with but
maybe I'm also happened connected
visiting people sir this is me who just
come back from school she was actually
ask you about the physics above still
you're a mass culture even out of you
need to like here oh my goodness so much
of what happened to that pub could not
be filmed the firehouse pub quiz is like
an x2 legend if you're an extra student
watching this definitely go at least
once because it's like a cult following
yeah the sex positions around the
musical chairs is a particular highlight
so it's currently like half 10 and I am
walking back home because I want to do
some more work when I was in the pub
actually bumped into to my friends who
have just done their Vipers and they are
now doctors they have their PhDs and
it's not so much a kick out the art is
the case of like I really really want to
get on with this now so just about the
time I am now going to go and do some
carrying
[Music]
so there was me mining my investments
just working and I felt something on the
back of my neck okay this is wearing
I've lost sight of them
this guy was just chillin on the back of
my neck and by British standards
he's quite a bigger I mean that's my
phone for scale this is a Sony Xperia X
so it's quite a big phone little bugger
oh just come down from the ceiling the
back of my neck got surprised oh my gosh
the more observant among you may have
noticed that I'm not working in my
office at the moment um I can you know I
have a shared office with other postdocs
and PhDs I start a place that having
kicked out
I just find sometimes I like to change
the scenery so I'm teaching to an acting
room no I am in the forum this is
actually this is pretty cool so the
forum has in it this like quat and
through the glass through there that's
like the main bit before man I was
sitting over at the top there by that
lady in the blue shirt now I mean one of
the seminar rooms looks out on this quad
because to quote Shakira
I am trying everything when it comes to
trying to fix continuity a problem so I
come in here to use marker and the board
to undo what's called rubber ducting so
rubber ducking isn't some ghastly
deviant act that you'd find define on
urban dictionary it is processed where a
programmer will go through the computer
program which is just sequence of
instructions the apartment computer and
talk to an inanimate object normally and
a rubber duck explaining what each
mining claim does and there is that when
you explain it to something you get out
of your head and you potentially spot
problems that you're not able to spot
just on your own so I'm gonna pretend
for the rest of the time that isn't
calling that I'm explaining the codes
what it does to you I hope that it you
know picks up something in my brain so
Rho is given by our C
weight as a function of cosine to make
sure you
equal areas all this [ __ ] work the whole
exact sequence and no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I still don't know what the hell's
going on and I've managed to get my
wallet locked in the campus club but
other than that stead going swimmingly
[Music]
we had another middle of the night
collapse last night so another pile of
books is keeping my bed up
that's three piles now should we gather
around the warmth of my laptop where's
your laptop yeah yeah really different
school so today the kind of weird Dave
um come on is like again it's not to be
a wet wipe my nose on my sleeve no about
staying in now okay so the three of us
by which I mean myself down and pixel
girl who is decidedly off camera we are
being the back row for a service which
means we are the bass tenor Alto for
quite otherwise made of kids at the
school in Exeter and we're just
rehearsing the music at home you shall
got my first bottle you okay i solid on
magnify the Lord and my spirit hath
rejoiced in God my Savior
a little ya winner winner
[Music]
obviously a counselor in the school so
we're going to go off a levy hit
and we're back it's the evening so I
think it went quite well actually
as the service goes it was was pretty
basic music you know like symptoms from
what we're used to but there were fewer
of us it was me and two other bases in
total and rather than normal six that we
have so I kind of had an excuse to sing
really loud which is appreciated what is
my hair doing past levels are so high so
since getting back we just chill a bit
and then I have been editing and you
might notice have done any PhD where
today this is partly because the same
thing disrupted the day and I thought
I'd work from home but also I really
need you to break a bone if you could
tell but yesterday I was definitely
close to breaking point when it came to
work just feel incredibly disheartened
that feels like I'm constantly fighting
to try and make - until equal 4 and I
get 3 every time is so so frustrating
and I hate having to take time off work
which probably in itself means that I
should have taken some time off so
taking a day to focus on singing and
editing getting one with a crash course
cries fear means I'm being productive
and I'm trying to give myself just a
little bit of breathing room so I can go
to it tomorrow and really attack it and
say well you know obviously something's
going wrong let's break it down even
further and hopefully if I could talk to
somebody in the office about an advocate
and then there's the small matter of
this huge series that we are only
halfway through and a lot of work still
needs to be done is currently typical
editing after five minute is eleven
thirty one and I am just going to record
some voiceovers Wow out of the whip pan
enough this set has almost completely
overkill for the purpose that we use it
for but it gives you really good quality
stuff Wow and this lighting makes you
look like a villain Dan how loud were we
doing the service today on a scale of
one to ten I'd give it maybe a 14 or a
felt very very loud it didn't help that
for those so those you haven't watched
time as video
about how an even song is structured the
sands it just so happened the some
chance and this particular times we do
think were brilliant
they tenor my fairly sure we went up to
an a its high and loud oh yeah and there
were points where you know it's loud
when the tenors are kind of looking at
synced up to watching how things are
going is going really well
and you see that you're going to be
shooting up for a room and it's not a
good sign very mind we're singing with
we were seeing with schoolchildren see
the two other little ones that I had on
my other side I say little ones they
were taller than me yeah yeah I wasn't
gonna bail out so I know why 50 maybe
120 rats pull rank that anyway they kind
of looked at me now a bit scared because
I was warming up this big note and I
knew they live in their grips below from
tomatoes looked at their conducts in it
and the kind of she gave the cue and I
was kind of like okay and then in my
head I thought be try try and have a bit
of taste know
[Laughter]
okay it's time to do this I just had an
early lunch at home this morning I was
working on finishing off the crackles
episode I've been trying to be kind to
myself and not think about work too much
because I've needed to recharge refresh
that's exactly what I've done now it's
time for me to go in sit down get to
work and fix this problem
[Music]
[Music]
hmm very interesting the plot thickens
because by fixing one problem I revealed
another one I think I fixed the main
problem at least so it turns out that
the major problem I had was the
integrator I was using which is
basically saying how the code was adding
up stuff underneath the curve because
you know it's easy to integrate if you
have a continuous function it's just
like high school maths but if you're
doing it on a discrete grid there are
different ways of doing it and the
technique which I was using for some
reason which I'm still not sure about
the function I was calling was doing it
wrong
so by changing that function out for a
different one it sticks the problem kind
of so what I'm trying to do is get these
two curves to match up right the red is
what you see in the real atmosphere this
is the average pressure over the polar
cap over the course of one year and the
blue is my reconstruction of it given
the amount of mass that's flowing into
and out of the polar region Wow it's
gone stripy and what you see is that
they match up really well here but then
it kind of goes a bit a wall that's like
a sine wave climbing but if you look at
the curve the cars are the same there is
separated so here they're in zinc here
they're in sync that's separated and
kind of for a bit here here for the same
set but separated but there's this extra
thing that's going on so there's like a
consistent addition over this time of
the year and a consistent subtraction
over like this part of the year now not
chef asked me some missing something on
me including something but it's a lot
better than it was
[Music]
so today is yet another weird day in a
week of weird days another non-typical
degra PhD it's only commented actually
saying um but this is unlike a typical
day for any PhD student you know what I
was talking about the vlog our today is
vary quite a bit because we're a
completely in charge of our time
say for example today I am working from
home I am continuing to sort the last
problems of these mass fluxes and get
them exactly aligned it like in a way
the the flux per day is now almost
exactly correct it's not quite and I
want to get it exactly right for I put
it in the thesis so I'm just pursuing
that here at home and I'm at home
because I've got a very exciting
delivery coming so I'm now arrived one
for you and there's a box for Simon so
in this oversized box which is very well
Big Bite yeah how do I get in here there
is the kit which has ordered with my
voucher from YouTube Nextup means
I pick up the new camera and that's just
what before oh it's just the conclusion
of our film in the restaurant of
conclusion nidian chess game what with
all of these
packing peanuts it's all of my warts
it's but I ordered can't you eat them my
god you can yeah you can't eat them
do you think I want anybody want to be
that many microphone which is a road at
videomic pro and dead cats and a selfie
stick because I had like tiny bit of
money left in my budget and I did those
no point wasting it so I thought I'd get
one of these things friend already know
yo what's up and guard yo and the main
event my new camera my cannon would
nearly dropped a TD I realized the last
time I unbox something on the video vlog
that was tech it with your Chris so if
we could avoid the same fate with this
camera that would be that'd be great
this is the debut file on this new
camera looks good so something so the
microphone can pick it up say something
says I might make a video you know hey
so this is my new vlogging setup
hopefully she'll be able to tell
something of a difference between this
footage which is like an an a TD with a
kit lens admittedly and the g7x
partly because the g7x was definitely
getting a bit old and lacquered and this
is newer technology and it is but it's
bigger and better really now you might
completely justifiably be wondering why
I wasn't shooting folks before on the
nicer cameras that I have like the 5d
which I use for sit down and shoot stuff
like for example when I read out all the
wit comments on my channel the reason I
didn't was because those cameras like
those I mean the 5d and a 600,000,000 I
have they don't have what's called
follow focus which is this property this
cameras so if I move the camera closer
to me it's might be fishing a bit far
but it looks like it's staying in focus
and if I move it further away it just it
I could actually see it happening that's
really cool if the cameras wouldn't done
that they'd lock from one position and
so for a vlog those cameras just would
not be impractical because movement
moving the camera around and basically
it's not being completely
ha static it's kind of a key
characteristic of the vlog so any camera
that doesn't have follow focus which is
called the g7x did have just isn't a rip
rip the disciplines to the specified is
that as you can see it's quite big and
by the month our hands probably shaking
much heavier than what I'm used to
[Music]
microphones are not able to make so I
came up on campus because the delivery
device like coming and I didn't never
get as much work done at home as I do
here living in the real eyebrows it's
currently six so I'm going to save a
little bit longer than I'm going to go
at home because this week's been a
little bit weird to work so I haven't
really accomplished enough to justify
not working weekends especially given
out later than the thesis so I'm going
to be doing a bit of work this week but
starting tomorrow got a lot to do on the
YouTube side of things I'd like for it
to be known as what I wanted I wanted to
take a shot up there but there's a bunch
of children playing and there is no way
the complete least would not be cooled
if I turned up with this setup
so I'm sleeping in way too late today
which was definitely planned not like
I'm just really tired or anything I am
recording audio for the next up vlog at
the moment like basically the plan for
this weekend is I want to race out as
much stuff as I can because I've got to
catch up on editing like I've already
said in this episode and I've like got
to do some production for it and it just
sucks because this is the stuff that I
really like doing like getting new kit
really excites me making stuff it's the
thing I enjoy doing the most like doing
this on the weekend having it relegated
to two days a week and not even full two
days because I will need to work
tomorrow
it's just like oh can I kind of keep
doing it like this is also my job got to
say I'm loving the improvement in care
that I'm using this is this is fun
although I will say that being this by
looking at myself in the viewfinder wow
that's not attractive people can
actually see what I look like a lot
better than before I actually need to
now start worrying about my appearance
although I draw the line I think it
actually wearing makeup apparently I was
told most male youtubers who do you on
camera work what makeup I don't know how
true that is
but I mean I do clearly
[Music]
okay you're a youtuber and your channels
doing pretty well so you're thinking
about taking things to the next level
and going pro noggin are kind of love
doing voiceover work because it means I
get to pretend I'm voicing a cartoon or
a David Attenborough film must be real
here how would you look at the time it
said it's a clock I'm actually really
enjoying editing this one it's a
different style of video than what I
normally do when I do a vlog it's
normally basically putting everything in
sequence and you know changing the speed
maybe including other elements like time
lapses whatever was in this case it's a
half and vlog and half white ermine
analysis video where it's a voiceover
with related images on top and in my
experience they're always a much bigger
deal to edit because you actually need
more shots than you would for a vlog
because typically people get border for
shots more than sort of like five
seconds more than five seconds long so
you actually have to be quite quite
creative and you also have to do some
storytelling in this case because it's
like oh and then we did this but you
need a transitional shots or like for
example
oh it's now night temps you need your
the time lapse that I did of the Sun
going down or an external shot it's um
it's much more like prop of filmmaking
which is probably what I'm enjoying it
so much if he's ever wondered what it's
like to be a youtuber and maybe
specifically like a medium scale
youtuber like me it's basically spending
a lot of alone time with your editing
software
so next up on the column very high next
up on the chopping block is Dan and I
doing a pilot actually this is like this
is a podcast idea that we had a couple
of days ago that in me down I am named
over cuz English student yeah we had
this idea we just wanted to try it so
we're going to film this this will
definitely grow by the time that this
goes live on sponge and electric so just
alive would be to start something great
or not at the start of something great
yeah
positive things outlook so I think that
actually went pretty well and I'm going
to edit that tonight but before I do
that Dan and I are going to go off to a
concert so of course I couldn't actually
record the concert because you know law
but it was really good it was not what
you call an easy listen but he's not for
bits of it and the program was like a
mix of stuff we only went for those of
you who didn't guess was because we knew
basically everybody in it we know the
cathedral choir people very well and
they sing very very well and it was
difficult music I can include links to
what was sung down in the description
because it's tough that yeah it's not
your normal fare there were some more
traditional pieces in the concert but
given that everything in the program is
written in the 20th century just one was
in 1998 some of its sort of pushing the
boundary of what we think of the
classical music in particular the
Westminster maps by Palouse Nick is
interesting for a few reasons not least
because it was written by a woman and
that's very unusual that you go to a
choral concert and you know get to say
that other piece it's a mass but it's
like extra movements in and it's yeah
interesting to listen to I'm going to
quote the program because it's far more
eloquent than I could ever be the
composer generates a kind of Pali
tonality in which cause a simple
Tennessee major and minor not with the
fleet in the peak and force relation of
music Anna Tudor era nor with a stark
dissonance of post-war abstract
modernism as there remains a sense of
key and
turn or hierarchy rather there is a kind
of the nine tolerance that postulates
that all notes can achieve harmony with
one another when the conditions are
right
the work is totally inclusive I do not
know enough of our music also the
concept is interesting because there was
English Old English Latin and Hebrew
being sung it's not very frequently you
get to hear Hebrew basically outside the
Prince of Egypt soundtrack in the
cathedral so yeah like I said I'll
include links down there highly
recommend you try them out and if you
give them a listen comment with what you
thought alright it's a new dawn it's a
new day it's a new life for me and I
have been editing this morning getting
the wiki cast episode out that's now
released on spongy an electrical
including link down there hopefully this
will have been a wild crazy success
already a lot of times comes out but
then I've also been working on the next
up vlog which is like 80% complete now I
need to put some pictures across I need
to edit this middle section with gap in
the time liners which is all that food
of Google and hopefully that'd be ready
today so Dan and I just had a really
nice lunch outside like a picnic II type
thing because it's such nice weather at
the moment and instead about very nice
weather we're going to go and sit in the
darkroom for like two hours and watch
the new film from Edgar Wright baby
driver there's so much to do today we've
got to do that so good idea as we're
seeing it so we can do a film review but
then I've also got I really want to do
some more work
I still got that effort that vlog
episode to finish off and I'm saying
this so we're just on the way to our
local cinema to watch baby driver what
are you expecting and I don't know I
think it's to be its it should be said
that we're both massive Edgar Wright
fans very much so I'm most interested I
think in a how they pull the story off
because I still through watching the
trailer it seems very basic yeah yeah
but I think most importantly owns the
other clocks there too a shooting of it
like cinematically yeah car chases are
that you can either do it really well or
it's a complete map yeah I think I'm
most interested in how they're going to
do the music
yeah is that such a big part of the
story as we understand it at the moment
and he's taking it through a kind of a
level that hasn't number four obviously
music's played a really big part in the
previous films I Scott Pilgrim is
probably closest yeah but um yeah we
were basically excited yeah we've got
high hopes for this cannot wait two
hours later I'm just going to do
everything I just did the camera again
because the microphone wasn't on and so
we just came out of the cinema seeing in
America right film savvy driver this is
just for the vlog and we're also going
to shoot this full Spungen Electric
episode I can see that that is visibly
frustrated ad I'm really cross I don't
know why I'm trying to be trying to
rationalize I interface where ya from
about 10 minutes in to watching so hard
like this thing it's not sitting right
with me whether it's the mindset that I
was going in was wrong perhaps I need to
see it again or perhaps our expectations
are too high I think maybe I don't know
maybe baby saw one thing that one thing
you can say about it is what they
absolutely nailed the editing ah Edgar
Wright comes always so well attitude
yeah ah come on I've never been this
crossed up going up felt right we're
going to go and fill with episode on
sponge electric I've include a link down
in the description I try want to watch a
B I was like convey what I'm thinking
rather the frustration I really to
pieces it was made this the the
filmmaking of this was brilliant who
made it so I got the episode finished
which is one of the objectives for today
we also went to see baby driver which
was an objective that we can't say
ourselves and record an episode not had
a chance to edit that though and I
didn't have a chance to do any work
which I'm quite pissed off at myself for
because I felt like I've let it take a
backseat more than I should have
so this coming week I really need to hit
it hard but this is wrong and how to
lead a blog because I'm going off to
pixel goals to have dinner
I'm going for a drink and you know two's
company three's a crowd or you know 18
thousand and three pound
I found a clever on my hand so yeah I'm
going to finish the vlog here do check
out dynamos view of baby driver which
I'll put down there in the description
because Dan has very strong opinions
about it and I'm sure he wants to get
into a discussion with all of you but
thank you very much for watching and I
will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]